[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
this
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
we're starting now what's going on you
guys
gaming guys here coming at you for
another addict show where we talk about
the past
present and future gaming i'm here with
a special guest van
uh you guys know i can't pronounce stuff
i'm gonna attempt to pronounce this
man's name
it's archimedes right archimedes
that was close
definitely appreciate you coming in here
you know there's uh as you could tell we
we're going a little early we're going a
couple hours early because
uh my my my friend is on the other side
of the the world
so obviously there's going to be a
little bit in terms
of scheduling that had to be
accommodated a little bit so
how have you been doing man thank you
thanks
so much for the invite i've been doing
great i mean just yesterday my youtube
channel hit the 4k
subscriber milestone yeah and today i'm
on the addict show so it can't get any
better than that so
i'm doing fantastic and thanks so much
for the invite and thanks for shifting
over your schedule just for me
like you said it's kind of late here
already in germany so appreciate that
um yeah looking forward to the show yeah
i definitely
appreciate you coming on man i
definitely appreciate you coming on so
we got a good show with you guys we're
gonna have uh
i think we're having a third person
joined here in a couple minutes you know
we'll have to see about that
but we got a good show going forward we
got some halo infinite to talk about
kind of want to break that down a little
bit more
uh mike volume is super low on addict i
mean
i don't know how it's low
okay all right what about now is that
better
is it definitely louder can people hear
me in the uh the stream better now all
right well we'll wait for that to catch
up to them
so i want to talk about halo infant a
little bit i felt like you know
the debate is officially over we each
actually got to play some pvp too which
was interesting
then i want to talk about this ps5 ssd
uh quote-unquote fix um you know
i i do feel like there is some some
things that we need to bring up on that
and i i don't necessarily think that you
know
i am done talking about this particular
thing then we're going to talk about
horizon forbidden west most likely
getting delayed to 2022
and how much i told people i was bright
and what
does that lead sony in terms of
a uh a lineup of 2022 yeah so you know
we're going to get straight into this
man
let's let's talk about this ssd thing
first man
uh mighty let's talk about this like
when you heard about this what was your
first thought process that
the fact that they are going to have you
beta test
for hardware i'm gonna repeat that for
you guys
you're going to be participating in beta
testing
for hardware
yes indeed uh what was my thought i
thought oh
cake twitter is going crazy about this
uh or over this um
and that's exactly what happened uh yet
this
this is such a weird thing to do to be
honest um
i i still don't get why it's a beta i
like you said it's
it's i can't remember that we are beta
testers for actual hardware this
that is in our homes and that we paid
money for um
however um it's also sometimes
um a little bit blown out of proportion
of course
uh on on social media the thing really
is for me
my first thought is okay just with a lot
of other things
on the playstation 5 sony is just doing
it as usually
um i mean in the last generation when
you want to wanted to exchange your hard
drive you also had to open up the
the ps4 take the hard drive off put the
new one in and this is
just the same thing it's exactly the
same thing the difference is though
that their biggest competitor made
gaming so convenient and the console
design
and then all that in the xbox one
there was you couldn't replace your hard
drive you could only yeah
true true that um there was a
workaround that only worked on the 1s
and 1x not on the base xbox one where
you were able to do that but that was
definitely obviously a hack
on the playstation 4 you were allowed to
do it at least yeah
and i mean this is kind of the same
thing i i don't think it's such a big
deal like some people
made it out to be because you just do
that once yeah
i mean it's not like you're swapping out
hard drives constantly um
and obviously it's a little bit more
work um than on the on the
xbox um side but um it can be done
the the thing for me really is what what
i thought is so weird
is first beta thing of course this then
the second thing is
that they really don't give out a clear
statement which hard drives should we
use
because you can assume that the casual
customer out there
will order the wrong hard drives um
yeah you have to think about so many
things now um not just read in
speeds you have to think about the heat
things you can have the heatsinks
only attached on one side not two-sided
most
ssd out there have the the heatsink
attached to
both sides yeah you have to think about
these kind of things and i bet that a
lot of people will purchase the wrong
ssd
that doesn't work properly um and that's
just
something that i find so weird and that
they take
that they put out that statement about
liability that they don't
take um any responsibility about the
hardware and what happens with it and
whether the game's run or not
and that's just weird to me so if the if
you do it like this
um your extension method
just put out a proper statement these
are the ssds we recommend
and we can guarantee that those will
work and and
they would be fine but this is just kind
of
weird i think the biggest issue we have
here
is just like how weird they're being
about stuff i i'm just like look like
if you i think this is entirely just for
legal purposes
i think they want to make sure that you
know something goes wrong you're not
expecting that ps5 to be replaced
so yeah it's it's what's funny is like
the people that are on twitter saying
this isn't that hard it's not that hard
it's actually pretty easy
the problem is is people have the
assumption that everyone has the same
tech
uh tech level that everyone has i i
agree with
you uh customer service like you'd be
surprised
how tech dumb people are like and we're
not talking
i can't say like my age and lowers
getting a little bit better
but my age and lower are still pretty
tech dumb in a lot of areas like
like they are okay when it comes to like
you know installing something
uninstalling something rebooting your
phone
closing apps down but the moment you ask
them to un
to to take something apart in any [ __ ]
way shape or form
you know sure it's not a lot of taking
apart you only have to to
rip the sides off and you have to
unscrew a couple screws but
to to the average person that is
that is a lot like that is a lot a lot
yeah yeah
especially nowadays um i mean consoles
have always been that
kind of convenience box that is a
disclosed
ecosystem that you just plug and play it
just works
yeah if you if you want to open up a box
put in an ssd
check the specs out usually you would
build a pc
and pc building um
got lost a lot less over the last
years because you people just buy the
the pre-built laptops they buy their
pre-built
um ipads and whatnot and um
i i it's funny that you mentioned that
because i just had the discussion over
the weekend with my uncle
because my cousin he is now 19 years old
um he doesn't know [ __ ] about uh
computers and how they actually are
built up and
everything because he grew up with that
ipad in his hands that just
that you just buy and and everything
works he never
built his own pc when i grew up you were
not able to buy
a pre-built pc or a laptop or something
yeah
my first pc i had to go to the library
and read books to to be able to
build that thing and and install dos on
it so
um that's just the stuff uh the average
consumer doesn't do anymore and now
i'm not saying it's that complicated but
you are absolutely right uh
consoles are usually that convenient
gaming box where you don't have to do
anything just plug and play and that's
that's taking away now yeah
yeah and it's like i said this is not a
big deal i don't want people thinking
that you know we're uh
that people are out here saying yo this
is the most inconvenient thing in the
world
it's not but i will say like it's okay
to say
that it's not that hard but it's still
an inconvenience yeah um
it's not look at the end of the day
there's a thing called doordash exists
all right do i want to go get my food no
is it them breeding it to me and
inconvenient lessens the inconvenience
yes
but i can still admit that i'm being
lazy because i want to drive up there
and do it
like so it's just like at the end of the
day like some people just don't want to
do none of that nonsense like
and then not to mention you got people
that kind of know what's going on
but then they're like yo can i break it
like
you know you got to think about like a
lot of people when they buy electronics
taking it apart is not on the table at
all
yeah true it's also um
i don't know about the ru the the exact
laws in in in the us but here in
europe every electronic device that you
sell has to have
two years of warranty yeah so no matter
what you buy
when it's an electronic device you have
automatically two years of warranty
but usually they have those seals um um
across covers and whatnot it is on my
playstation 5 yeah if you open that you
lose warranty and
and that to remove that sticker alone is
something
um yeah i think he said i don't think
dude do you break
the the warranty sticker doing this
i i think it's deeper i think you have
to go deeper into the system than just
the ssd to break the warranty
i don't know though but i'm sure someone
in the comment section probably
knows definitely i haven't opened up my
ps5 yet so
i can't tell but i've seen that sticker
from
from uh um from a lot of videos and then
yeah it's it's sad man because it's like
at the end of the day like
i'm not even disagreeing with this
selection that they did and how they did
it
i'm just like why is there beta yeah
to test switching hard drives out
because to me that screams
we're com we're unsure because we
haven't done enough testing
so we're going to put out the word beta
on it to blame you if it happens
like yeah yeah but yeah that's the
the topic about liability yeah um just
put out a statement these are the hard
drives and now they are working
um yeah but you know we've seen that
they they've
low-key did that but guess what it came
down to it they they're like
these are the ones that work but i'm
just saying i don't know
if they're gonna work like it just it
feels like
it feels like it's so unprofessional
what they're doing and i think that's
what it comes down to
it's just like dude like there shouldn't
be this many
jumps and hoops just to switch a hard
drive
like and i've stayed from the uh from
the point i don't know if you agree with
me
i feel like the ps5 was rushed out the
door i feel like
uh you know they probably i'm not saying
that they were slacking when it turns to
you know research and development
but i do feel like you know something
happened
or they didn't finish that that design
quick enough because first off i've said
it over and over again that playstation
does not look like a uh
the ps5 does not look like a playstation
design at all
no not at all uh yeah um
i i've heard that argument many times
and i thought about it many times
i'm not sure if they rushed it out i
think they
they were just surprised by the
competitor um
and they had to to adjust a couple of
things
on a short notice um to to accommodate
uh
what microsoft was doing um we've seen
similar things with the og xbox in 2013
yeah that
we that the whole concept of the
of the original xbox one was completely
different and they changed
the entire console concept within six
months before launch
um and it kind of feels to me like
that was what was happening with the ps5
when xbox announced the specs of the
xbox series
x very early on i think it was in
february last year
january february where they had that
digital foundry hands-on and and we got
the
the baseline for all the specs i think
they were just really surprised by it
and then you got to think that just
because when we found out they probably
knew before then
like i have a personal theory because we
all know the playstation 5
is overclocked i personally feel like
they saw the difference and the power
between the ps5 and the series x
that they're like we're not living a
series x
uh an xbox one x and a ps4 pro all over
again
for twice as long so i personally feel
like
maybe that system was designed a little
bit differently
a year and a half before it came out and
they had to redesign it to
accommodate for the overclocking heat
that they do
then yeah yeah exactly so exactly my
train of thought yeah
the chip was more or less ready probably
not with the same specs than they saw
the xbox series expects and the only
thing they could do because they
there was not enough time to change the
actual chip design yeah what they could
do is
overclock it a little bit a little bit
maybe change a little bit the heatsink
and everything
um the cooling and and then rush it out
the door
um it's just
how it felt to me when when the ps5 came
out
um i still think it's it's a good
console that the problem from
from me is with a lot of things on on
the playstation right now
um it's just they are doing
so many things just like they did in the
last generations
um while microsoft is innovating on so
many spaces
on the back compared size of course with
the
features like quick resume auto hdr
stuff like that then we have um of
course the value
with game pass and everything um then
the convenience with all my controllers
work the the extended hot
drive with with just the little card you
plug in
stuff like that they made so many
innovations with the system
while sony is just doing business as
usual um
but it's not enough anymore when your
competitor is so far ahead in terms of
convenience features
value etc um
yeah that's just what we're seeing right
now
i've always felt like look like a lot of
xbox fans demand better games from
from xbox and we do it all the time but
it's just like
i feel like people look games
are extremely important in a gaming
console
but absolutely features are important
too
and i feel like that energy is never
given to playstation like
you can still it's like they act like
if the if the engineering teams that
make the console and the software
developers
make like gifting on playstation it's
going to make horizon a worse game
like i i've never understood that like
like
the the features between the xbox and
the ps4 i mean
the xbox series x and the ps5 are night
and day at this point
and we should absolutely we want the
industry in general to be better we want
the industry
on playstation software to be better we
want the industry and
on xbox's games to be better and i feel
like it's only ever really
highlighted on the the xbox you know
it's just like you know like
more improvements can happen to just
xbox
yeah i can read 100 it's it's kind of
i made a video about this a couple of
months ago um
on the difference in between the two
hardcore fan bases while the xbox fan
base is really criticizing microsoft for
stuff when they came out and increased
the gold price yeah or
like you said the games the community
has been demanding games for years now
but the playstation community is not
that vocal when
it comes to criticism of their of their
brand
yeah and yeah like you said um
we should should as a as a gaming
community
um speak up when when we need
improvements and
sony definitely needs that on the
features uh software side right now um
i mean don't get me wrong i i really
like my playstation 5 it's
it's i've been i've had all the
playstations ever released i've i'm a
gaming fan through and through i
own all the consoles and i own a very
decent gaming pc
but sometimes when i turn my playstation
5 on it just feels
um like also the ui and everything is
not really thought through
entirely so why do i need like 10 clicks
now to turn my console off
when i go to my installed game section
why can't i see
how much um space i have left on my hard
drive
it's these little kind of things that
are just not thought through
um if you compare that to the
their competitor and people were really
criticizing xbox for not having a brand
new
ui when the console launched and
everyone was saying
oh it just feels the same yeah just a
little faster
but at least everything is working it
everything is in place
like you said the features are there
it's and they have been constantly
adding month-over-month
stuff here frame rate boost was added
two months after or three months after
launch of the console stuff like that
is added constantly and i haven't seen a
real update
up until this beta of the hard drive now
um on
the playstation side yeah um but
also the fan base is not speaking out
about this
and i think a lot of it has to do is
like you know me we say it all the time
on the iron lords podcast
i'm getting tired of this mindset that
people could do whatever they want
as long as they make good games it's
like no
like i don't care no i don't care if
fable comes out is a is a colossal hit
halo comes out to colossal hit a vowel
comes out to colossal hit but perfect
dark comes out
a colossal hit if they do something i
don't like i'ma still call them out
like like it's just like just because
you make good games
don't mean you could treat me bad as a
consumer because i
because you can take your good games and
i will still leave them
yeah um i've said it many times
no platform holder should have that kind
of self-confidence to come out in a
or start a new generation by increasing
game prices
this is just something if if
a if a platform holder is that um
higher up his head then something is
wrong and that's why we need the
competition we need that pressure
from microsoft nintendo and now coming
also in steam with their um device
um we need that competition because
no platform holder should be um
i don't want to use the word arrogant
but i don't know a better word
right now they're going to fool
themselves they are yeah
um to to to do that and like you said um
they are making great games some awesome
games
out there but yeah what is the reality
i'm sitting here
debating with myself um game prices are
now 80 euros in germany that's
like 93 us dollars for a playstation 5
game and that's
kind of to me where i draw the line
that's a that's a real investment now
yeah uh that's why i didn't buy a game
like return
i just said okay that's not a 93 us
dollar game for me
yeah yeah it's like i think i just feel
like people
they get too prisoner of the moment and
you know look there obviously are xbox
people out there that's
claiming everything's fine with games
there's playstation people out there
that's claiming everything's fine with
that but to me
like as far as content creators in this
community
i do not see the same energy in terms of
them
like i i hate when when you know i i
was like look let's call playstation out
for for the ghost of shashima 10
thing they're like but these xbox people
did this i don't see this i'm like
not talking about that first off but why
you keep bringing up random people i've
never heard of on twitter
acting like that is the the mass
majority of xbox people
and then when you ask them for like a
link of proof showing what people have
say that everything is fine then they
just go crickets or they block you
because they know that when it comes to
just stating stuff
out of your ass is fine but when i
demand those receipts
they disappear yeah
that's that's how fantastic uh out there
it's it's really funny um because um
i when i started being a content creator
and and getting
active and a bigger follower base on
twitter i was constantly posting about
um me enjoying games on on my switch on
my playstation on on my xbox of course
obviously the xbox is my main platform
that's where i play all
the third-party games that's where i
have most of my friends
um i'm still enjoying playing on my
playstation though
but as soon as i say something good or
bad about either of them
i'm i'm constantly getting blocked
pushed as a
or labeled as a fanboy of one on the
other side
it's really crazy it's you can't say
anything bad about
any of the brands even if you if your
criticism is
totally valid and like yeah during this
e3 i got attacked because i
i just stated i wanted more from star
field like
and people was like oh you've got no
right asking for that
and i'm like look like it might
like to me they at every corner
they might not necessarily have been
hyping up star foot but they mentioned
it at every corner
like the first meeting in the first
interview
that was done after the studio was
bought was between pete hymes
todd howard aaron green uh uh
phil spencer and i think it was either
sarah bonner aaron greenberg i can't
remember which one of them was there
but they literally brought up starfield
as an example
of their their companies mixing like
they held on to the star field
they held on to the starfield being
exclusive for so
long to drop that at e3 and you needed
to tell me they weren't hyping that in
any way shape or form
like no like i'm sorry the amount of
energy that they put
into this game yeah and then you want me
to sit here and act like a 30-second
trailer that didn't show nothing
is okay is never gonna fly with me
yeah i i feel you there um i
i really like the e3 press conference
from xbox really did
um that was the only negative i had
i had another thing i i i had that
problem with the cgi trailers a little
bit too much because when i
thought about it well all the xbox first
party games have only been shown with
um with cgi traders we have not seen
during the conference any game blame for
outside of forza horizon uh yeah for for
the experts first party games
um but my biggest criticism i and i have
i totally feel you i was in a direct
reaction show after the
conference um and i said i was a little
bit disappointed about halo infinite not
with the way how it looked but that they
have not shown anything
properly from the game yeah we didn't
get gameplay from the campaign and we
only got that montage of
um killcam shots from the multiplayer
at that point they didn't announce yet
that there is a
deep dive coming tomorrow i didn't know
about that because they didn't say that
during the e3 show
and so i went out
yeah they brought it up like an hour
after the show ended um
horrible immediately after the show i
was there okay and
that is how you show your biggest game
of the year
of obviously they corrected that the day
after with a
very good deep dive and halo looks
amazing and everything but
uh that was was a little bit my takeaway
from the
from the e3 showcase and when i said
that publicly oh dude
the fanboys came after me just like man
like
i can disagree with something but still
understand why they did it
like yeah and i understand where you're
coming with the the
the halo thing because it's like how
hard would have been at the end of that
trailer to be like
for a deeper dive watch out for tomorrow
you know what i'm saying like
that's all you have to say like people
want me to like
believe that that that that type of
wording is just gonna destroy the whole
conference
like but you know it is what it is
i don't want to go too much into that
because because i i could rant
all day about fanboys man so you know
let's go ahead
and talk about this horizon forbidden
west
getting moved to 2022 well it's not
beneficial but
it's official like if you think this
game's coming out this year you're not
paying attention
and i've stated on isle lord's podcast
every sunday at 1pm that this
this game is not coming out this year i
remember getting attacked because i was
so
adamant about it look at the end of the
day
does that hurt playstation yes because i
i do believe
that that's gonna make that's gonna make
halo come out even stronger
because they don't really have any
playstation game to like
be compared to because we all know even
though that these two games should never
be compared
people are going to compare them
definitely definitely so
what i want to ask you is do you think
this game coming out
hurts their 2021 lineup because besides
this game we only really have ratchet
and clank returnal
and uh because demon souls came out last
year uh
i mean spiderman two came out last year
yeah so i mean turismo has also been
delayed to next year so
i am um yeah pardon me yeah i just
personally feel like
you know this is something that we
expected but no one wanted to admit
yeah um i'm right there with you i also
expected that for quite a while now um
it's actually right after they shown
that that
deep dive gameplay sequence i said that
game is
never going to come out this year um
the thing is um first
let me let me say it's a good thing to
delay a game if a game is not ready it's
i'm always pro delaying give the
developers the chance to polish the game
in a manner um that they intended to uh
that it will help us gamers all the time
however obviously um their lineup then
is this
week this year really not that strong
if you look at the last couple of years
they had like
at least three four major uh
releases each year i mean last year was
insane with the last of us ghost of
tsushima miles morales demon souls etc
that was a fantastic lineup throughout
the year um
and final fantasy 7 remake and and
whatnot and this year
yeah return and ratchet even though
ratchet was awesome i
really enjoyed that game probably in the
top five of the games i've played this
year
um yeah it's going to be weak
whether it hurts them is a very good
question because
they are still selling every console
they manufacture right now
so does it really make a difference for
them um
to if they release that game this year
or not
if they sell sell out all the consoles
that they can build
and the difference between sony and
microsoft is that
sony is their business model is still
relying on selling the actual console
everyone
could always argue with microsoft that
for them it's not just about console
sales anymore for them it's more about
engagement with their entire ecosystem
yeah they're also happy if you play on
pc or buy a cloud or whatever
uh on your smart refrigerator wherever
you want
this that's the difference with sony for
them the success of the business is
still measured in
in by selling console units and if they
sell everything that they can build
does it hurt them if they don't release
that game this year i'm not so sure
yeah i i i agree with you
i do feel like it does hurt them to a
point it's like i said
i think maybe because here's the thing
like optic wise it looks bad
because it's just like you know you
delay this game out of 2022
but i do feel like next year
where is it going to come out like is
god of war still coming out next year
because
no i personally feel like god awards
2023. so listen god of war was
originally intended to come out in 2022
they they never planned for that game to
release in 2021 in the first place
i don't know how anyone can believe that
that game was always planned to come out
next year but now with the pandemic
being
like or running for like one and a half
years now the actual delay
is from 2022 to 2023 i think god of war
is a 23 game
i do too and you know this comes out
next year
obviously it's it's going to be a
phenomenal game
yeah but when i saw you know horizon
forbidden west
it's not that i didn't think it looked
impressive it did i just
what i saw just looked like pretty much
what the
first one was just looked a little bit
better like
and to me like i don't want all this
hype going into this game even when it
comes out
it's disappointing because people
expected like a variety of different
gameplay changes
and it's just like and i all i've always
been the kind of person that feels like
if a game gets delayed the expectation
for that game goes higher
because people oh i have to wait for it
okay i'll wait for it but is it going to
be better
why was it delayed and i i think that's
a problem with the
you know the consumer base but i do
think that exists like for instance you
you know every time halo's been delayed
i feel like that tick goes up and up and
up
like and that's why i'm a big person
that
if you're going to announce a game you
better make sure you at least
have a general idea of when it's coming
out the pandemic is different
we couldn't expect a lot of the stuff
that's going on with the pandemic
but you should never have been
announcing release dates during the
pandemic at all whatsoever er
because at any time uh you know kobe
could spark up again
people have to go home like at any time
any of this could happen
you should never do a release date
during this type of scenario
and i think too many people it's okay to
announce a game it's not okay to
falsely announce a release date and i've
always felt like god of war
they should have got more backlash for
that like they announced last year that
god of war was coming out this year
and i'm confident they knew it wasn't
coming out this year yeah
like and people's like oh they're just
doing this to generate hype
it's okay to generate hype it's not okay
to lie to people yeah yeah
100 percent basically guarantee very
important yeah you can say we have that
in the pipeline
and if you are if you are are um
confident to keep that release that you
can name or release it but you have to
be really confident um
i agree with you there um you never
should lie and we have seen that
unfortunately too many times right now
yeah
coming from them yeah and it's just like
look like
they could have easily went on there and
they could have easily said
um you know god of war ragnarok's been
announced
didn't put no formal release date or
anything whatsoever on there
and they would have been fine i don't
know why they put a release date
unless they're trying to hype you into
buying a ps5 out the gate
yeah yeah and that's probably what
happened um
but i it's i still think they they would
have achieved the same hype if they
would just have said the game is coming
coming soon something like that yeah um
it would have generated the same height
but you didn't
feel or we as the customers we wouldn't
feel like being lied to
yeah um and i personally feel like
people were letting sony get away with
this too much there was
the we believe in generations thing you
know sure we clowned on them people
clowned on them
but i don't feel like they got a lot of
heat no uh
there was you know they literally put
gran turismo
coming to oh like they literally put
it's only a playstation 5 exclusive
and then when it came to putting them on
trial for that
people it's like people forgot about it
in two days
there was no date i made a video about
that because they had that
conference september last year's
some someone in september had that that
their second big show of the of the year
and jim ryan said in that interview
and i quote now we believe in
generations and literally
one minute after that show they posted
the blog post where they announced that
horizon
and um one other game is is coming
also to the playstation 4. um that's
just ridiculous if you think about it
there was
really no backlash for them about that
but they let when microsoft announced
that they let
microsoft take all the heat the people
were really coming at microsoft
therefore
holding game development back and
whatnot and
and now we see that um they're taking
the same route
actually i think microsoft has announced
way more
next-gen or current chen exclusives and
then
their competitor you know what's crazy i
remember like a couple years ago
i don't know if you was around by then
but microsoft
just talked about a game being cancelled
before it was announced
and i remember the amount of attacking
that this
that they got over it they're like oh
you yeah then i'm like they literally
never announced this game we didn't
i don't think they had a name it was a
code name and the amount
they got more hate for that than sony
literally
lying to the consumer base and you know
i feel like the only thing that they
actually lied about was the
for uh the gran turismo being exclusive
because
i feel like a lot of this stuff they're
just conveniently leaving information
out they're not really because
you know they said oh this is a
playstation five miles of morales
and look we're just gonna conveniently
leave out there's a ps4 version
so and then when it comes to scenarios
like this it's like okay
do we expect a ps5 for a ps4 version of
games now
like should i buy a game uh ps5 knowing
ratchet and clanks only in the
playstation 5
when you have deliberately hid this
information am i
is it fair to assume that i would assume
that maybe ratchet and clink will come
out for the ps4 eventually
yeah yeah um
like you said um they just leave the
informations out
and that's it comes back to transparency
that's what we have seen
microsoft wasn't good at that a couple
of years ago but they have changed
their marketing strategy when it comes
to that
they are being very transparent and they
take a lot of
of heat for it because typically when
they announce something new
um something that gamers are not used to
um the first thing is that they get
attacked for they did that for the
question approach for the backward
compatibility they took a lot of heat
for that
um and yeah
in the end it's transparency i know what
i'm getting
and we also see that with the game
lineup itself
um microsoft has announced right now
well 22 no actually it's 21 now because
the flight simulator
has released 21 first-party games now
um that are in the making that's
transparent roadmap
if i invest now in the xbox ecosystem i
know exactly what i'm getting
in the next couple of years the next
three years i will be getting
like 22 or 21 um xbox first party games
plus a couple of course of second or
third party deals
what do i get on the playstation side
they have announced gran turismo
for um god of war and horizon
three it's we know that there's more
coming
um but it's not that they are
really transparent they just stay silent
yeah they are skipping all the major
shows e3 gamescom is coming up in three
weeks now
um yeah
um it's one thing i've always felt like
if you don't want to make a conference
that's one thing
but i get it you don't want to spend
that money because that that's
realistically what this is about
but it's just like i think you owe it to
your fans or at least be have a presence
on the floor
yeah absolutely absolutely and
it's so weird to see because last
generation
i was always like man sony is so good in
being
transparent laying out their road map
and people
always said that they're announcing
games way too early but
i said at least they're giving they are
selling
their system on hope because they you
know that the games are coming down the
line yeah
and now it's kind of reversed yeah
microsoft has laid out this
amazing road of 21 first party games and
we know that they haven't announced
everything that they
have coming up here um but they have
already announced
21 first party games amazing
roadmap clear transparent statements
from the executives and everything
um and and sony is is completely
um the opposite of that right now
yeah and i feel like there is a scenario
it's like look like i get it
sony they're trying to keep a lot of
this stuff close to the chest you know
what i i think it really is i think that
sony's never dealt with a competing
microsoft like this
and now they they're trying to figure
out and test the waters before they jump
out of the plane
it's like we don't want to commit to
something
and then microsoft does another move by
buying something such as like sega or
something you know what i'm saying like
like i i honestly feel like sony is
scared of the
you know the the money that microsoft
has because i think up until now
sony's been aware that they have money
but they're like they've never really
used it so we
we don't know if they would ever do
something like that but i i think when
they
when because look i got my ear to the
ground people tell me stuff all the time
no one told me about bethesda no one
so i know they were keeping that on the
lock lock low
so sony most likely didn't know that was
happening
imagine them finding out if they did
find out when we found out like
that is a third party publisher not
developer publisher that's that
microsoft literally came out like we're
taking our ball and we going home
so i feel like sony ever since that
happened they're like
we got to be careful how we move because
they're not playing anymore yeah they
and i think they've been very
very what's what i'm looking for
observant on what happens
yeah it's it's a very good point
they have to figure out how to be a
competitor
yeah and like you said of course
microsoft has had
always the money the difference is
though
now they have the dedication of the
mother company and
they gave phil the actual tools in the
hand in terms of
promoting him to the board of management
and that he can actually
organize that xbox structure within
microsoft properly because it's not
enough to just
buy studios if you have like 23 xbox
studios now
you have to be able to manage them
that's not an easy
task yeah sony they have grown over the
years
they learned how to manage all these
first-party studios how to
make release plans for the games in the
pipeline and so on
and that's something microsoft has to
figure out and
money alone doesn't help but they are
learning quickly and they are doing
all the right moves right now and uh
and and sony is is kind of
now in that position where they have to
be reactive to what microsoft
is doing because microsoft is giving the
pace in the industry right now
yeah they are ahead in terms of
innovations features
value in gaming and so on and and
i think sony is is now really trying to
to figure out how to be a competitor and
not just
that guy uh that that company that that
just sells the consoles because the
their competitors don't have the mind
share in the gaming community because
that is
shifting rapidly right now you see that
through that the positive mindshare that
microsoft has right now
even throughout the mainstream media
that were like
criticizing xbox one year ago heavily
yeah they
there seems to be a shift in that
mindshare and sony needs to learn how to
deal with that
and i think that they are i think that
you guys people in the chat you got to
understand like what kind of
what kind of scenario this is with them
they've never dealt with a microsoft
like this they've never dealt with
someone
that is disaggressive look there is a
difference between someone that has a
little bit more money than
them and someone that can buy your
company six times
if they were able to
the fact is that i mean they might be
able to buy them more than six times i
don't even know what playstation's worth
these days
i mean sony's worth these days like it
is a rough scenario to go through why
you think they
they've been so aggressive like we've
seen you know contracts saying that
you know we never got clarification but
it looked like sony's trying to prevent
games from going a game pass
uh sooner uh on day and date because at
the end of the day that hurts
the entire point of a marketing deal is
if you could go out there and you could
say oh
oh you got a marketing deal for uh for
for this game for you know
let's say what's a let's say far cry 6.
far cry 6 got to mark you to a
playstation and if they didn't put these
in place
microsoft just comes up there like we're
going to pay you money day and day
game pass at that point your marketing
is dumb
who cares no one cares anymore
because now everyone is more important
on like
yo we see this on the trailer
and we see it being marketed by sony and
the people was like
was it on game pass like like
and i think that's one of the reasons
that they're working
in this kind of direction is because
they do want to make sure that
you know they want to they're kind of
testing the waters they want to see
exactly
how aggressive microsoft's going to be
do
let me ask you a question do you think
they would have bought um
the people who made return if microsoft
wasn't being so extra with money
ah good question um i'm not sure
microsoft has
when when they looked into their studio
acquisitions they have always looked
do we have a certain chemistry do we
have a history with that studio do we
know how that studio works internally
because we have worked on previous
projects with them
um that's where they or how they
they looked at studio acquisition so i'm
not sure if they would have bought a
house mark
um if sony wouldn't have picked them up
um
because they don't have that working
relationship
with that but it it it's
in the end it that the thing really is
like you said
um it's just a different way
in how sony needs to look at things
right now um
in terms of their marketing marketing
deals are not that important anymore uh
even um third-party uh exclusive
exclusive deals are not that significant
anymore because
uh let me elaborate um
i always say should microsoft do that
these kind of third-party deals like
they did with final fantasy 16 now or
something like that
should microsoft do something like that
i don't care if people can play a
certain game on the playstation or not
as long as they bring it into game pass
because i as a gamer don't get an
additional value
when when microsoft pays a certain
amount of money
to lock a game away from a certain
platform
but i as a gamer do get a bet additional
value
if they bring a day and date game pass
so even that
that kind of of strategy is
mixed up with how microsoft changed the
industry right now and
and yeah sony needs to adapt to that and
i i'm glad they need to because
um i don't want people always confused
that if i say
stuff like that i don't want microsoft
to win
quote unquote the generation i want them
all to be on par
because that's when we get the most
competition i want them to
fight for my wallet that's where i as a
gamer i'm a selfish gamer the area
i get the most benefits out of but if we
have a situation like in last chance
where
microsoft would dominate now at the the
generations significantly and um and
sells
like double the consoles um like like
sony does like we had it vice versa last
gen
and i wouldn't i wouldn't benefit from
that i would i want
just a proper competition want them to
be
power on power and fight for my wallet
because i don't
ever want that situation again that a
platform holder comes out and
brings me a tv tv console at launch or
the arrogance to increase game prices to
70 us
or 80 euros respectively yeah i don't
want any of the platform
holders to act be able to act like that
anymore and that's why we need that
competition
yeah it's like i said like i actually
have a little bit more of
like a different take when it comes to
that i know a lot of people feel like
timed exclusives aren't important but
the right time to exclusive can can turn
stuff uh
for instance pretty sure we're never
gonna get final fantasy 7
on xbox if not it's gonna be like years
later
and you know we're gonna let's say we
finally do get the remake
we're gonna probably have to wait the
same amount of time for the remake too
it i have a playstation 5 pretty much
solely because of that game
so you know like i do think the right
timed exclusive is a very important
thing
um but you know let let's talk about the
bread and butter man let's
this halo infinite man did were you able
to get into the beta
no unfortunately not i did not get an
invite and i
had to watch a lot of streams because i
was really
excited for the game and i had to watch
all the people getting excited and talk
about the game on twitter
um but i wasn't able to to play it
myself unfortunately
so i've got a two super chat from raiden
blight
sony as a whole is worth 84 billion
dollars so microsoft can buy them
way more than six times
but it's just like at the end of the day
uh is microsoft willing to spend that
kind of money
probably not i don't think even if
microsoft could buy sony i don't even
think they would want to
to be honest with you i i think that
that
that's come and gone uh for the most
part
so what from of the halo franchi
from halo infinite's uh tech demo
did you see that like what was something
that you really liked and what's
something that you like kind of got
confused or you didn't like
okay um what i really liked um
is people said that a lot in during
streams when they played it
or on twitter and from me watching the
videos
um i've seen that the gun play
is really on point um they they really
did put a lot of work
into the actual gun play it feels
heavy it feels precise it
it comes back to the ochi halo
things where halo was always about skill
the halo multiplayer was always a skill
based um
multiplayer and and they optimized that
gunplay
for exactly that and i really like that
um that
that that's exactly what i want i want
this shooting to feel good
i want to want to have that powerful
impactful gun play
um that's that's what what really stood
out to me
that you don't need to play the game to
see that this is this is
definitely some strong suit of halo now
um
yeah what did i not like um there
weren't that many things that i didn't
like
i didn't like people trying to
actually find every little bug in that
in that beta it was a technical beta
they didn't even call it a beta they
they call it a technical flight because
they wanted to iron out
issues yeah and people a lot of people
just
were looking for bugs and then there was
a glitch or a crash or
even that fruit physics thing i don't
know if you have seen that
um where someone posted a clip
and tried to shoot a melon or something
in the
in in halo infini in the halo infinite
beta and it didn't
have the same physics like a call of
duty clip
um where they shot a certain fruit
that's so stupid
that's what i didn't like it is it is
actually it is very confident from
microsoft because they knew that this
was going to happen
they knew when we put out a public beta
with no ndas whatsoever
everyone was able to stream post
whatever they would like to
yeah no nda in places like things like
that
is the reason there is ndas like yes
exactly it's like yeah this look am i
saying that that's gonna be different in
in the real game no it's probably gonna
be the same but at the end of the day
why are we focusing how you could
destroy fruit on a map
like that is like look i will say there
are
certain things that it does come to
importance
in terms of you know the the attention
to detail like
games like naughty dog they build their
whole game around attention to detail
yeah microsoft is not building through
uh
microsoft did not oh well not microsoft
343 is not building halo infinite
to have that kind of attention to detail
like we should be more caring about
what how the game feels how the game
plays uh you know the weapon balances
the map balances how the maps are made
then we should care on whether or not i
could destroy fruit in one
or two shots exactly exactly
yeah and to be honest yeah that is
actually it has shown me that they are
really confident now in the product
to bring out such a such a beta
or technical flight without an nda where
you know exactly that everyone is going
to
look for the slightest bugs
and they will bring out all the glitches
and post those pictures on social media
and they still had the confidence to put
that out
just shows you how how good and
confident they are in
in their game and that's something
awesome um and
yeah i hope i get in the next flight
what did you like about the
have you played it yeah i played about
10 hours let me get this super chat real
quick we had a ten dollar
shot uh from raiden blade tied to
exclusives very soon
uh these are no longer going to be so
easy in the future for
sony to lock down because of game pass
if r
uh if ratchet clicks of 1 million there
is 10 million ps5
the look of mlb
the show across two platforms i do agree
with you i do feel like
it is going to be harder for them to
lock down timed exclusives that may be
necessarily harder
it's going to cost more money because
not only are they going to
buy that marketing in terms of you know
how they market the game on their brand
they're gonna have to buy the right
to not have that game on game pass so i
i think this is gonna
you know unintentionally raise all the
marketing
because the good thing is when microsoft
does marketing
they don't have to market stuff going on
game pass
they can just market to market the game
for instance
when they've got battlefield it's it's
still up in the air if that's going to
be on uh
games with gold they could go to them to
just get
the price it would cost to do gay uh
to to get the marketing for that game
they don't have to go to them and say
yo how about this i'll give you this
amount of money to market it and i'm
gonna give you a little bit more on top
to make sure don't go to playstation now
because no one got no one cares if it
goes to the playstation now
and you know i i think that you know
they know that that would put
some some value in playstation
now but they know that if they did do
that
chances are sony's not gonna double
commit and triple command and get other
games in there
and they know for a fact that sony's not
even looking into getting that game in
the playstation now so they don't have
to pay that
pretty much service tax to make sure it
doesn't go there
uh you got a two dollar ship from raiden
blade mob's
uh 4 million sold 2 million on xbox sold
and ps5 2 million it's interesting man
it's interesting
yeah absolutely um those those um
numbers uh have been out there
and it's really it just shows you
how many of the actual playstation
gamers
buy the exclusives that's that's
i was surprised by that to be honest um
because i thought
at this point in the in the console
generation the console is mainly
purchased by the hardcore game embrace
yeah
and they should definitely go out for
for all the exclusives
when you're at the end of a consort
generation where you also have a
big play a a big amount of casual gamers
as an install base yeah that that
percentage that buy your exclusives
probably goes down but this early in the
generation i was really surprised about
that
yeah now look when it comes to roll it
back a little bit when it comes
to halo i feel like this is one of the
only times i can honestly say
i feel like halo infinite and the halo
franchise is in a good place
i don't think that halo's ever going to
be back to where we're used to be
and there's multiple reasons for that
one of the reasons
is we could just be honest that the
competition is way more than it was 10
15 years ago
and i don't think that you know they did
do a good job by making
it free to play so they can't compete on
that level but
i don't know if this game now look
fortnite
looks like a casual game but when you
get into the competitive thing it's not
a casual game
but you could still play that game in a
casual way and not still feel defeated
when you get killed you get redeployed
right back out there if you wanted
you're right back out on the field
on on halo it's going to be different
like you're going to come across people
that you can't outshoot
coming into halo you're gonna have to
get better so i feel like maybe that
skill gap just a little bit
is gonna be enough to where they're
going to have to
you know it's gonna be harder to sell
and it's not necessarily harder
to keep people to sell people on a free
to play because you'll be able to do
that
it's going to be harder to keep people
in the game
when they're going to get mopped by a br
a couple times
i feel like a lot of people will they'll
flip out
yeah so we got a two two dollar super
chat from raiden blade
uh archmedes ps fans are all talk no
action
sorry i agree he's talking about the
sales
yeah yeah um
like i said i was surprised by that but
but let me ask you a question about hey
like that
uh i agree with you um like when halo
comedy wolf came out it was really
the revolutionary shooter on consoles i
mean
i played hundreds of hours of goldeneye
but it was a different level then
um and and now we have with call of duty
battlefield and all the other shooters
out there in the field
so much competition that halo didn't
have in
its first years i've seen a lot of
people say
that this game halo infinite now is
still um trying to to innovate
where innovation is is required but
keeps that
original flare of halo do you agree with
that
yeah see i would my assumption on here
is uh let me get this super chat real
quick two dollar super chat
uh from dan rios definitely butchers
your name we're gonna move right past
that though
uh halo's biggest hurdle is the fan base
and i agree that they have they have a
lot in the fighting when it comes to the
fan base
i think halo has incorporated enough
of the older halos and they have
innervated it
and made it a little bit more up-to-date
as much as they could without making
that older fan base
uh pissed now like i understand i'm with
people 100
we need sprinting we need ads and a
modern shooter
but at the same time i cannot blame them
if
they don't want to make someone mad that
help build the franchise
like to me i feel the same way with
final fantasy they changed that
franchise drastically multiple times
they they pretty much spit in my face as
a long-term final fantasy fan
for a newer audience and it's blown up
in their face in general
you know i i personally felt like final
fantasy hasn't been the same in years
so i can understand their point of view
they're like look
we understand that there's a lot of
people that want something new for halo
but what you guys got to understand is
we cannot spit
in the face of the long-term halo fan
we're going to have to find a middle
ground
what's up forte we got gaming forte
finally joined in here uh
we're uh i i know he's played the halo
beta correct
absolutely so so at least like you at
least you know
i got you know halo uh wait wait y'all
didn't get into the basement i got into
it but uh the boxing door
didn't get into the beta i didn't get
into the debate i know
oh man so we got that we got to find out
what's going on my archimedes supposed
to have been up in their day one
so i'm gonna ask you i'ma ask you the
same question i asked him
what is the thing that you enjoyed the
most and what's something that you could
have went out with or they could have
changed
uh the thing that i enjoyed the most is
the overall the way it felt the movement
i know some people are a little bummed
that they took the um
the dodge and the thrust out of the game
um
i was more of a component of like okay
it's a thing i did find myself like
wondering where it was
and it wasn't even something that i was
really keen and loved in halo 5
but the fact that i when i went to play
it i was like yo where's the thrust at
it kind of just hit me and i was like oh
okay but just the movement in general
like the fact that they have it so you
uh
more walk at a faster pace and then
running so you don't even really have to
run in this game you can pretty much
walk everywhere and it's
a more faster uh better experience now
uh
yeah go ahead i'm unsure because i
didn't really get the concept of this
you know like the
yeah the the the vision thing where it
would like
spring across the the map showing you
where everything is if you push up
yes there was a couple of times i saw
people on that
yes to so what i was told is if you're
running you show up on that
you do you do so that's
how do you feel so part of me you show
up on radar if you're running
compared to that well that was that
wasn't even a radar i'm talking about
the thing
that you that you press up on the d-pad
it's not even on the radar
i guess you wish you know wearing this
button yeah so i guess they consider
that part of the radar too
like to me what they're doing there is
they like look
we're gonna add running but if you're
being
less aggressive you're going to never be
on their map
well the thing is it is it's an extended
radar
it only shows people it doesn't show you
running
on radar if you hit that situation but
awareness button
if you're not next to the uh point of
interest
like some of the power weapon armors and
stuff like that if you're
close to those things and you're running
it will show you
on the map or not show you on the map
but it will show that outline of you
it kind of gives you an idea of how many
people are heading in that direction
so you can kind of plan your attack to
be able to attack that um
area of the map like you want to with
different teammates and stuff but if
you're walking
you don't show up on radar and you
wouldn't show up on that ping
so it was like a really good game take
it was like one of those necessary game
change elements i think they put in
because
at first in halo 5 if you were running
you couldn't regen your health until you
stopped
in this you still run but you reject
your health at all times and your
and your health comes back pretty fast
it comes back way faster than it came
back in uh halo 5.
so i think that was kind of the olive
branch they threw it's like okay we're
gonna let people
move around the map really fast but
you're always gonna be on radar if
you're always abusing that um
that movement yeah and i think that's i
think that's fair
like yeah it's very fair like if if
you're
being aggressive and you show cause let
me keep in mind i played about 10 hours
of the game
a lot of games i only saw one time where
someone was on that radar
so but i didn't notice they were on that
radar
so i do like that they're like look like
we took some of the
the balancing it things that we did in
halo 5 but what we're going to do
is we're going to keep sprinting because
we know the newer audience
wants that sprinting they want that ads
we're going to keep where if you get
shot in ads you're going to get shot out
of it
and we're going to keep uh we're going
to take away the the regenerating thing
because
i think a lot of people didn't like that
in halo 5 where like if you were running
while you're
uh if you're running you couldn't
generate shields but what we are gonna
do
is the only time people show up on your
radar is that they're shooting someone
or if they're running
and i think that you know that punishes
people for
not playing more of the foundation i
halo
and i like that i think that's good
because like i think
you're going to see people start to to
run everywhere
but then when you know when stuff starts
to settle down
people really figure out how to play
halo infinite you're going to start
seeing people play less aggressive and
not running a whole lot
yeah i i think that's an interesting uh
component is it in every game mode or
is it is is this um locked to to certain
game modes
you talk about what the ping system or
what yeah the ping systems
it's it's embedded in the game like ap
pledges is okay
it basically calls out um your ai will
call out point of interest is on the
screen
um it would i don't think it calls out
enemies
just yet i don't remember seeing it do
that but if you're looking into
it basically just highlights all of the
equipment and power weapons and stuff on
the map
um and if you're running like if the
other team is running
close to it it will ping them also
so it's awesome so after hearing that uh
because i know you didn't get into the
beta like
do you feel like that's trying them to
be a little bit more
you know honoring the traditional halo
um definitely i i am i wasn't aware of
that that didn't came across
while just watching a couple of streams
and videos
on idle that this system exists but
that's actually quite a good idea to
stay true to the og x-bar ochi halo
experience while still innovating with
that modern shooting
what you need like you said sprint ads
is just stuff you'd
kind of need these days in a shooter but
um
good to hear that they thought about it
well
see that the what i like that they did
is they continue to keep the
what we're gonna do is if you because
halo's always been a
uh it's been a hit fire game yeah and so
they're like look like we're gonna give
you the ability to aim down sides
because
people's like oh aim belt sites we don't
like that halo
no you don't like that and weapons you
don't use let's be real here
they didn't mind aimed out sights in on
the br
so like they didn't mind aim down sights
in the sniper rifle
they just mined it in guns they didn't
use right so i'm just like look we we
got to be more fair to other weapons we
can't just have two weapons dominate the
whole market
so they're like look like we're going to
keep it to our
if you're shooting with the br with any
gun
and you get and you're and you're in
that aim down sights menu and you get
shot it shoots you out of the aim down
sights
so it's like obviously when you when you
come up on someone
you'll be able to effectively shoot them
a lot easier
but then the moment they turn around and
they start shooting you
if you still have that ads up you're go
your shot's going to be less accurate
because they're constantly shooting
yours
out of theirs and if they turned around
shooting and hit fire
they're probably going to win the
engagement just because they are not
being shot out of theirs
right um what i think about that
and i actually think that's a good
compromise but for most people
go into one win again when you get a
chance to because this won't be the only
technical beta they're going to do
they're going to do more and they're
probably going to be more focused around
the pvp side of it
but um when you get a chance go into the
armory
go into the but the barracks and use
those weapons against those moving bots
and put it on like the three-star
version of it that will basically teach
you how
the engagement limps are going to be
with certain guns in the hip fire versus
having an aim down sight
for the most part you only have to aim
down sight if you're shooting something
from extreme
distance and none of the maps in this in
this beta really
benefited from that i think you're going
to see more
like you know stuff like blood goats or
valhalla stuff like that when those maps
start
showing up with long sight lines and
long distances
that's when you're going to see aim down
sight come into play because
at that point it's going to be who has
the better you know aim when it comes to
that
but as of all the match we played on in
this everything should have been hit
fire for everybody
because if you were trying to aim in
even if they were shooting you with the
sidekick which i think it's extremely
underrated because
that thing puts it work in hipfire um
that thing will knock you out of ads
every time so
i think it really just comes down to
just getting maps that really benefit
the aim down sight portion of the game
but nothing that we saw in the beta of
the three maps they gave us really
benefited to that so
i would wait to those later maps and
those bigger maps come out to start
actually doing that
let me ask you guys a question um
obviously
multiplayer is going to be very very
dependent on maps and maps size
like what how many maps do you think
this game's gonna have at launch and
what type of map size do you think it's
gonna have do you think it's gonna have
like
more of the map size that we saw there
do you think they're gonna have bigger
maps
what'd you think um um
it's a good question they said they will
support that game for like
what 10 years i'm talking about launch
yeah so um i think they will probably
launch with a
with 10 to 12 maps i think they will go
a bit above
their biggest competitor battlefield um
this channel
this this fall season um so something
like that 10 to 12 maps
would be my guess and they will have
like two or three really big ones
because i think they will bring back
some sort of
um multiplayer mode like that um what
was he called in halo 5 the war zone
mode or something like that
um big team battle
yeah it wasn't big team battle it was
that yeah he's talking about
the pvp pve there was war zone i don't
well i think
or something i think that will come back
but i don't think it's going to come
back anytime soon i think when they
bring that back they're going to bring
that back if they do the battle royale
and they're going to interwove that into
the
um battle royale experience
you guys think they will will implement
some sort of battle royale oh yeah
it's gonna it's gonna happen yeah i
don't think so
it just it just seems too
right for halo i i wouldn't hold up on
that that answer too much uh
mighty's man i wouldn't hold up on that
too much man call this man by his real
name he's right his real name
it's archimedes archimedes look man
archimedes
you guys know i don't pronounce stuff
very well and there's definitely don't
pronounce
other languages stuff very well man like
look man you guys just gonna have to
deal with it man i need you to go to
that man's
youtube channel he says about the 16
[Music]
times
i wouldn't hold on that too much
archimedes i wouldn't hold that
that thought process now look here
here's here's my issue
i love the game but i don't like the
thing
with the the shield thing i don't like
that like
i felt like i would prefer the bubble
back
are you talking about the um the
basically the rally barricade
yeah i would have preferred the bubble
back over that that thing is
useless it was useless i mean people are
saying they put it behind them that's
all cool and dandy but
oh like if you're running away and you
drop it and it blocks fire from behind
you i mean i can see that but that's
i felt like it would have been way more
effective if they brought that bubble
back we haven't seen this since halo 3
and imagine the fan reaction
if they didn't tell anybody that that
was in this game
and you did the tech test and you used a
bubble
like i just that bubble was awesome man
they actually made a whole
cinematic trailer for just that bubble
that was one that was one of the most
iconic halo 3 trailers that came out
with the bubble
oh where he was like uh he is is the
chief
is the chief is the chief dead right
because his helmet was laying on the
ground and he picked it up and then all
you saw was um
the western days just the rapes just
shooting um
yeah threw a bubble down and got hit
with a wraith bullet
that we're the rape bomb i was like yo
that's what that's what halo that's man
halo that's what i'm saying man like
they brought back so like bring back
some of the old
har the old equipment man where where's
the power drain
you know what i'm saying like like i
remember like
you know you would punish people for
for team for for trying to come at you
with like groups of three or four
with that power drain you would just
throw that up on top of like a ledge and
and that all their shields were gone and
they were like what about it over and
over again like
remember the power lift yeah the the
portable power lift i think that
might have been a halo 5. i can't
remember but like
man let's bring some of this equipment
so you missed some of the equipment that
they implemented in four and five
no the uh i don't think the bubble was
has been in one of what a bubble was in
three
but i'm saying but like all the other
stuff you're talking about basically
four and five
yeah i feel like the equipment could
have been better like the
i like how you can use it whenever you
want i think that's cool
but i felt like man let's get some of
this
old stuff back man we got to fight all
this street some slow-mo
backslap fortnite once had uh had a mode
where it would be a massive teams like
25 to 50 on their huge maps i could see
343 eventually doing something like that
completely agree with you i think that
what they're going to do is they're
going to roll stuff out in waves right
now you're going to get arena
and you're going to get big team battle
six months now to a year then they're
going to drop the battle royale
and then that's going to be playing six
months to a year then they're going to
drop the new war zone
and i think warzone's going to be
redesigned to what you're saying slow-mo
so archimedes mighties or meaties damn
it
i don't know which one it is but i'm
you're getting that you get it
so what is your personal
expectation when it comes to halo
uh i went i i think
since since uh 343 did actually a good
job with the multiplayer in halo 5. i
really like that multiplayer
um i my biggest expectations is about
the campaign
um i want i want that goosebump
feeling like i had in in in the original
trilogy and maybe even in reach
when i played through the campaign i
played through all the campaigns with my
buddies
uh in a split screen usually we used to
do that in local spirit
split screen actually except for halo 5
where they took that out
and so i hope that local split screen is
coming back here
um i think they've already confirmed
local
in the game didn't they fortunately i
think they did
i think they said something after the
launch of halo
5 like five six years ago when they said
something like yeah
they want to bring that back but now
they haven't really
confirmed that it's in the game um
yeah but i that's that's what i want i
want that epic campaign where i just
just get lost in the in the story and do
that
do that legendary run with my buddies um
that that's that's my expectation for
halo that they really nailed that
campaign
so what is your expectations forte do
you feel like
like i because i personally feel like
halo infinite's multiplayer is in a
really good spot right now
uh and it's so good i'm willing to say
if that campaign's good it's going to
get a 90 plus on metacritic
uh because halo infinite has two players
split screen a four player online co-op
that's awesome so it's only yeah it's
it's confirmed by three four three
it has up to two players so you know how
halo
three have four player this one only has
up to two
but it's still co-op uh through the
whole single player
awesome so what were you saying what is
your expectations in terms of this game
but i try to stay away from expectations
when it comes to halo because i've kind
of been disappointed on both sides
like on both sides of it at certain
points i felt like halo 4
had a really good single player but the
multiplayer was left to be desire
and vice versa the opposite for hello
five
i liked what i saw now if i if i just
talked about just the multiplayer i
think what they have is great i just
want
i wanted a faster moving halo i didn't
want it to be
a slugfest i wanted them to kind of
innovate on the idea of movement inside
the game
um i think like i said it's take it or
leave it some people are going to miss
it they don't have the thrust i think
it's a great idea i think
um it should come down to positioning
versus just a get out of jail free card
when it comes to your movement
and that's something that the game is
going to definitely um
definitely promote i just want them to
have
i just want the game to work day one
because that was that's kind of been the
overall arcing issue with a lot of games
over the course of the last few years
and
i just want this game to you know i know
there's going to be issues day one
because there's always
going to be it's free to play a lot of
people are going to be jumping in day
one
um game pass is going to be day one so
there's going to be hundreds and
hundreds of if not millions of people
trying this game day one so
i just want them to definitely make sure
that this game is 100 ready for prime
time when it does release
and the multiplayer just be exactly what
we got in this beta
and um just integrate on top of that and
don't
don't leave anything to chance you know
give people exactly the hail experience
they want because
i do agree with attic on the one thing
you know
sometimes dee brought like the core halo
community can definitely
ruin the way that halo is actually being
perceived because they do need to
innovate on it
but i do think they need to take into
consideration some of the things that
those people want because those are the
ones that are going to be playing the
game long term so i want to see kind of
a meeting of the mind when it comes to
that
and um i definitely just want to see
more and more people get into the game
and try it out
and i think the being able to have bots
in the game i think that's going to be a
really good way to get casual people in
because if you didn't play over the
weekend before
they put the spartans in there man it's
kind of crazy
you know i ain't going to say i lost to
them and all but you know
i had to get used to basically that way
of playing the game which has been kind
of a while since i did that
but it's gonna be fun and i just want
them to just make sure the game is good
day one
you know not good in the work not good
in the game places but good in a working
sense because
we have seen so many games like
outriders be
so good on day one we see it with the
ascent right now
people love the game but all of these
issues kind of detract from that
and i don't want to see that with halo
because this is
this is it for them they they already
said that this is our plan for the next
10 years
and you don't want to start out the gate
on a bad foot and i don't think they
will but that's the only thing
i want them to really focus on is giving
us the best experience day one
i agree with you that i'm right there
with you especially on
on the game being busted now as long as
the single player works like
i'm willing to even be a little more
acceptance if like we have network
issues
the first day you know what right
exactly because there's not a whole lot
you could do about that
but three four three don't let you don't
let me
catch you this campaign is glitchy oh
yeah let me
catch you letting this campaign be
glitchy man
because i'll i'll go live right there
man i don't even care
i don't even care if the multi
i'll go live and just talk [ __ ] while
i'm waiting to get in
like because i it's not even just three
four three i'm just so
sick and tired of games not running
correctly
like i just had this issue with you me
and kid smooth played that
i was having mad issues i get it
small team made by like 10 people i get
it
but i don't care you uh at the end of
the day it's not again it's not a free
game
you're charging money for this even if
it's on game pass
you still got to pay 10 or 15 a month
for this
it's not free stop letting these
companies do this like
like i've gotten to the point where you
know how they took
cyberpunk off a playstation
i've gotten to the point where if a game
runs like this
or like like kind of the scent having
mad mad mad technical issues
yank that [ __ ] straight off these these
platforms
because i feel like enough of that
happening
these people will let them fix the game
a lot of the time you have these
publishers that's rushing this out
trying to get it out so they can start
collecting profit off of this game
and it's like i feel like if if the
industry
starts to retaliate
on broken games that's when we'll start
having this stuff fixed
imagine a world
where they have to sit here and talk
like okay you know
you right now it's okay the game's broke
we can fix it later
but if it was not financially good to
fix it later because
yo if we do that man playstation go yank
our stuff off their platform
xbox is going to do it too let's give
them six more months to make sure the
game works
like like look i'm not talking about
network issues
not talking about that i'm talking about
games that are released
like cyberpunk like the ascent because
if you guys tell me
that they did not know the ascent was
broken i'm gonna tell you
that they lying they they knew it was
broken
i don't know um i i have to to
play devil's advocate here a little bit
because i played the ascent
pre-launch uh had a review code and
obviously the server load wasn't big
that um i had have not had a single
issue and the day it comes out
suddenly code didn't work properly um
i'm not saying
they don't have the issue but i think
it's in this case really a server issue
because
pre-launched they didn't have that yeah
i played a pre-launch of kids movie than
i had i actually have
multiple gameplays recorded on my pc
right now
of it happening and it's like like you
look maybe we had different experiences
but i know four people right now that
had issues
that one of them was reviewing the game
had so many issues
that he started the game over again by
himself
and then he had to play the rest of the
game by himself because he got tired of
the issues i had
the menus crashed on me that i had a
bunch of issues
yeah i think if we could get if we can
get
the experience that we got during this
technical beta
if we can get that day one on a mass
scale with the people that we're getting
i'm good with what we got there was
issues on day one people were disc we
were talking about people were
disconnecting from the server
you couldn't go into games with
teammates on the first day
because they would drop you and that was
fine because you were still able to get
into the game and enjoy it
um the next um day it was perfect i
didn't have any issues at all so it's a
testament to them and
getting that stuff up and running the
way it was um set up to be
uh i just want that experience
throughout the whole thing
um because i see some people in the chat
saying that it's a technical beta and it
was
and i think it was one of the best
technical betas i've ever seen because
compared to what we've been getting in
full game releases that's what the
problem has been
so i do
want to point out i brought up the
gameplay of me
uh doing it you could see that i'm i'm
stuck in the menu
uh there's no indication anywhere
whatsoever that
i have to press anything uh i i
continuously unplugged the controller
plugged it back in
i pressed every button you on the
controller it
this happened multiple times like it
happened started playing it again
see right here it started working fine
uh i think it
it happened it happened twice on this
gameplay i don't want to
look through i don't want to waste too
much time but i enjoyed what i played on
the game it's just
it was buggy em i'm sorry to hear that
because
like i said uh i had that issues um
after launch
um especially on the um xbox version i
i mainly played the pc version prior to
launch because they
sent the review codes out for xbox like
two or three days
uh prior to launch i i had it about a
week and a half before it came out
and the xbox version yes was there a day
one patch for it
so it might not have been a week and a
half it came out the 29th
i had it i believe let me look at my
calendar i think you had it like three
days before no i had it i had it the
saturday before
the saturday okay yeah i had now i had
like the two weeks prior to launch i got
the pc code
and then like uh two or three days
before the launch i got the xbox code so
i mainly played on pc
i only played like three four hours
before i started my review
um on the xbox and
but as soon as the game came out i
played a lot on on the xbox and
um then i started to have these issues
exactly what you've
shown here um but i did like i said
i didn't really experience it prior to
launch nevertheless
i'm 100 with you guys we shouldn't let
developers use us as beta testers
um we are still customers um we are
paying for that
like at exec we are paying for the for
the games
may be through game pass or uh when we
pay them full price
um do you know what should matter we are
yeah
outriders is a very good example to me
that game
still has issues major issues and
that it's not okay to test your games in
the field
um so yeah
very good point forty very good
expectation for halo let us
play the game in a polished state
especially after they
delayed the game for like a year that is
the main reason
i said what i said because if if this
game was just coming and i still had the
expectation if it didn't get delayed
but i think a lot of people have a
little bit more of an understanding
because
every game for some reason comes out in
this fight i just think the fact that
they delayed it for a year
and they had a technical beta and
they're going to have multiple ones up
until that point
we shouldn't like i said if i could just
have the experience i had
the day the technical beta came out and
that be the worst of it
i'm good you know what would be crazy
you know how they would fix all this let
me read these super chats real quick i
apologize guys
pay those bills i went to the ascent
rant and uh
we got five dollars super chat from
jared back all held the iop just showing
support definitely appreciate it man we
got a
two super chat from raiden blade is
there really an issue with the ascent
not me
uh i show i showed you the issue i had
well that was just one of the issues
a couple girls for not having an issue
but you know
what happens if game was busted
on the stores it just automatically got
halfton price
everybody would be hoping for a game to
be busted day one like
you know see you see when we want
something
that means they don't want it so like
like to me
it's it like if they started becoming
like actual
punishment for broken games it would be
fixed
real quick yeah
but yeah i mean the example you brought
up with the cyberpunk is a very good one
um that's that's that's how you get to
the developers
if they wouldn't be able to sell a
broken game they wouldn't release it
and true we got to just get to the point
where we're like it's not acceptable and
you know i'm the same way when it comes
to a game i really really want to play
i i could literally be told by 10 people
reviewing all the games busted
i'ma see if it's busted for me like
but you know it is what it is like at
the end of the day when it comes to halo
just have the game functioning have that
campaign be good
now i used to think that the campaign
needed to be amazing
but now that i know the the multiplayer
is in such a good spot
that campaign just don't let it be halo
5. that's all you got to do
you make a great campaign keep that
amazing multiplayer exactly how it is
you got a home run
like i don't know man they ain't getting
away with that multiple that single
player they can't get away
i can't let them get away with that
here's the thing though here's the i
can't they
i can't i i hear what you're saying
because i feel the same there's a
difference
the multiplayer is gonna definitely help
that game stand out more than anything
but i ain't giving them no pass on that
single player there's a difference
between
having a solid single player and
dropping the ball on the single player
and they got to do they got to do more
than just not drop the ball though
i don't think that well that's what i'm
saying like they have a solid single
player
and they have that multiplayer how it is
now i think they have a that's
considered solid to you though
i mean it's subjective i think we got
all considered something different
like some people i mean what like if you
had to
if you had to come up with a game that
was just solid to you
what would that be it wasn't mind
blowing great but it was just solid
what would that game be uh
i'm trying to think of a good example of
a game i played recently
because i feel like it needs to be uh it
needs to at least be on the level of
titanfall too
good i don't i just finished the call of
duty cold war campaign
how was it i didn't play it yet yeah
solid
yeah you know well call of duty
campaigns are solid they're
they're just short yeah they were sure
there was a
very weird ending um it's the typical
call of duty um action
over the top action sequences and and
what not very short
extremely short yeah uh this at this
time it was
i i think i played like three and a half
four hours and it was finished with the
campaign
yeah i have a feeling so that was solid
they have to at least give me i mean i
know it people and i
and people say it all the time titanfall
2 is one of the best single player
campaigns you will play in the show so
they have
listen they don't have to give me the
best singing that's why i'm saying well
you said yeah
please well no the reason that i say
titanfall 2 is because the gameplay
married with the story was great like
unbelievably great because the gameplay
is just phenomenal
we know what halo's gameplay is we just
don't know what the story is
if they could at least hit the marker on
the story type that they gave us in
titanfall 2
like the way that it was coherent it
made sense it actually branched and
you know brought other scenarios into uh
focus from
what the whole faction of the mic and
stuff was i would be good with that
because i know what halo's gameplay is
the thing that about titanfall
2's game play nobody saw the iteration
on the first one that they did on the
second one and then you just married
that with a great single player can
single player mechanic and story that's
what made that game stand out above
everything halo we already know it has
story elements
they have a breadth of content from
books to expanded universe that they can
chip into
the bandits is being a part of this game
for the first time
and i know we saw look at it we were
sitting there look let me get close to
my mic
attic when atriox was mentioned
as being in this game you lit up like a
christmas tree
because that is the first time that we
felt like ever since
probably halo one or two that we felt
like halo has a distinct
villain that they can really focus on
and it don't have to always be about
chiefs i'm gonna say something that you
ain't gonna agree
oh you go please tell me i definitely
think that they have
they have to deliver on the campaign but
if you think the campaign
is going to be like titanfall 2 level
i don't think it's going to be titanfall
2 level in gameplay but i think it's
going to be titanfall it needs to be
that an experience of the single
the the story has to be i wanted to but
i don't think that's happening it needs
to
i'm not saying that's going to be make
or break it could it could still be okay
but
i'm looking at it from a fan point that
the la
okay halo fours can't it has to be
better than halo force campaign
well that it's easy because
the form was good yeah that's what i'm
about to say about the art halo 5
no no sorry i was like at i think halo 4
is is is a great campaign is where i
would
say that they have to level halo 4 for
better
and tactical i'll give you that if they
give me the halo 4 campaign i'm good
with that
if they get yeah the thing about the
campaign is
i want like i said i want that that the
epicness that the first trilogy had
that you remember the first time the
flock uh
appeared on screen yeah that was such an
epic moment
halo 2 had so many many goosebumps
moments in its campaign and the ending
of three
ah awesome i want that again the problem
is with halo
that franchise is now 20 years old and
to retire moments like that
yeah and the the entire story the lore
everything is with books and everything
so well let's call it complicated right
now
and they have to kind of do that
soft reboot where they can also bring in
an entire new generation that play hater
for the first time
because um yeah it's been too long since
the last game and
too long since the franchise exists um
to to really get
everyone on board with the story so they
they they kind of have to do that soft
reboot
um while still maintaining
or satisfying the hardcore halo fan base
that is like there for 20 years now
and that is really challenging
especially when you consider that it's
a not an open world game but a semi-open
world dish
game with side quests and what not on
the on the halo ring
um and and i wonder how they will make
that step this is really not easy to to
bring in that
new player base and make a
understandable story for them also
satisfy us hardcore halo fans because
i i am a hardcore fan yeah i
i also recommend to everyone by the way
to play the halo wars 2 dlc
to get prepared for halo infinite um
but yeah i'm not the only one who's
going to play that game
here's mine and here's my word uh
arca archimedes archimedes i'm just
middle man middle man i'm about to just
pronounce your name as both just so i
know i get one of them right
you know we make it short call it call
me archie then
aren't you there we go archie
oh my god i like that archie okay archie
this is my fear for halo
infinite they have too many variables in
a story wise that they can't
realistically tell everyone's story that
they want to tell
so they're going to have to do it within
dlcs
throughout the next couple years that's
my personal fear and i think that's
what's going to happen
the vanilla is going to be the banished
then probably at the end of vanilla
they're going to have some kind of hint
on cortana or the flood showing up
there's just so
many different types of variants going
on different variables
different story thing you know cortana
by herself is a beast
they didn't really talk about her at all
in these
in these dlcs to my knowledge have they
so that's dlc is not yes
i'm talking about uh in these trailers
to the game they really talked about
cortana
i don't think they've talked about
cortana one time if you think about it
like there's the the original one where
once
they came out and there was some energy
coming outside
but during this e3 they had that um
trailer where where
um the chief talked to that new ai
and i think it was she was mentioned
there that she's really dead
yeah so they did talk about her there
i'm referring to what's going on right
now
like because it feels like what wherever
that was took in the story
cortana is no longer a threat
something's already happened
like i don't i but to me
how you gonna explain banish cortana the
flood
all in one story i think it's impossible
and i think that's why i say they need a
kind of a soft reboot to to explain that
that lord that story the background to
everyone it's it's
the only way you can do it you know what
that reboot's gonna be
i gary i can't guarantee it but
i say to your plan by year seven you
will not be playing that's the master
chief anymore
you said my years by years side you know
be crazy if they're building up your pvp
character
that's what they're i was just gonna no
liz listen you
remember mass effect galaxy at war where
you had to promote your multiplier
players to the single player campaign
they got this whole academy thing that
they're building you up through to make
your own
car your own guard your guardian jesus
your own spartan uh
way too much destiny um build up your uh
spartans um online identity
i'm trying to at some point during this
10 years
not saying because i don't i don't want
master chief to go away i just think
their direction is going to flip and
it's going to be
more about the character that you
crafted throughout those first seven or
eight years
culminating with you becoming the face
of being the next spartan didn't be a
master chief
i think it's going to be a slow burn
they're going to get they're going to
weed people on that
as they tried to do it in one game with
lock and that definitely didn't work
that's what they tried to do
yeah locke had his own tv show but he
should have had his own game
should have had his own game he should
have been more of a build up and i think
i've always felt like lock should have
had his own third person
cover action adventure games yeah
because they could have because
because that's actually explaining how
he turned into a spartan like yeah like
why did he try to do a spartan like
the probably like the game could have
went in like the beginning he's still
with odsd i think that's where he was
he was an oni or is that still odsd just
like a higher branch
i don't know i can't remember but uh
they said i just made his internet crash
with that statement so
like what will happen is you throughout
the game
you you just push yourself more and more
and then
sometime in that game he makes the
decision
to because it's a risk trying to become
a spartan you could die very easily
yeah so he he he becomes a spartan and
and then that's probably
like that's where the game is you know
what i'm saying like you do the last
mission as a spartan
and that would be cool because it would
show you the difference between a
regular person and a spartan
but they didn't do none of that they're
like we're gonna put this dude out there
we're gonna
he replaced the chief looks
general said it said you're seven i'm b
he said i'm betting
in the first campaign expansion you'll
be not playing as chief
look look that's just me being
optimistic i think it's gonna happen a
lot earlier than that it just really
truly depends on
the story because like addicts just said
the one good thing the one good point
that he made on that is
there is so many stories they have to
like kind of
integrate into finishing out with you
know finishing the fight with chief
again
um especially since they're rebooting it
tip a little bit
i think they have to get through that
stuff and depending how long it takes to
get through that stuff
that's where you'll start seeing that
you know
ushering in of another protagonist or
i think they want to do the destiny
route where is your
character who you perceive as your
avatar
being the one that you're going on these
adventures and stuff with and that's
going to be the long-term investment
inside of a halo infinite
i agree so is there anything else anyone
wants to say real quick before we uh go
and close this
up your camera's looking really crispy
sir
yeah it is i appreciate the uh uh the
the compliments on my camera so before
we close up i got one thing
now that we played the multiplayer i
don't care if you guys don't care about
metacritic i don't but i'm curious
what's your metacritic score thing that
you think now because we're not going to
see any more
of this game i don't think i don't think
experts
we might see like another single player
trailer but as far as that
i think it's pretty much over until we
see this game come out
forte what's your metacritic score
prediction i will give you a three
point curve swing three point curve
i think 87 to 90.
oh damn that that's what's yours
are occupying yeah um similar right
go slightly higher 90 89
to 92 i'm gonna say
85 to 88. you're crazy
85 to 80. how much of this is the three
how much of this is the three four three
effect you got going no right
actually i i've had a lot more uh you
know faith in three four three years
because you know i it's just i feel like
a lot of reviewers they're going to care
more about that single player than they
care about that multiplayer i think that
single player is going to be a lot
better than you think it's going to be i
hope so man
oh my god please let me be a hundred
percent i
i want to be a hundred percent because i
think that for some reason i feel like
they're gonna have like a lot of holes
they're not gonna tell stories very well
like because
i don't know i don't know we'll have to
see i hope that i'm wrong i hope they're
i hope this game comes out and it's
amazing but only time will tell
it it's just i want what's best for halo
and i think that they're doing really
good
in points in terms of a halo multiplayer
but we got to see what they do in the
future when it comes to how they're
going to interact
with this campaign and i think that's
the biggest question
but first off let's go ahead
uh anyone else got anything else they
want to say
we go okay we're good his name is
archimedes say it
five times where can the people find you
man
and i want to formally publicly
apologize for butchering this band
like four times man you're good you're
good man
oh thanks so much for the invite and i
had a blast here on the show
really awesome to talk to you guys here
and people can find me basically
everywhere and
we're under the name boxenberger um
on twitter xbox live playstation network
and especially here on youtube where i
have my
small um youtube channel where i do
commentary videos about the gaming
industry
um each and every week so yeah um that's
where people can find me
and thanks again for having me here i
appreciate you coming on my uh
forte forte forte
where can the people find you well they
can find me going to a barber shop in a
second to go get my hair cut is about
that time
um but when it comes to me on social
media and stuff gave me forte everywhere
youtube twitter xbox live playstation uh
check us out on dps podcast this
thursday on my channel
with the illustrious slo-mo backslap who
is in the chat right now
saying that all the stuff that we've
been talking about for the last couple
of
last 30 minutes he mentioned two years
ago so shout out to him
and um yeah at it great show as always
glad i was able to come make one of
these with you so proud of the work you
put in on this stuff
and um much success in the future sir
you guys got the
what's that dude got to do to get on
this uh this dps this week
have you been on dps not in a while
oh you wanna i mean because the last
time
the last one we did i was messing around
with my camera
so i didn't really get it like engage a
whole lot but listen
listen slo-mo says forte telling someone
about butchering names listen i know how
to pronounce
archimedes name though so guess what i'm
going to make sure that i let people
know
i'm going to scream that man's names
from the rooftops because i can
pronounce it so be quiet
and slow-mo so our friend attic here
wants to
jump on dps this week so um let's hit up
in the dm and see what we can do on that
okay and uh i definitely appreciate
everyone for coming through uh
you know i gotta read one super chat
real quick we got
we gotta get you on there too archimedes
one of these days oh
i i'd be happy to we got a five dollar
super chat from uh
dana roas yeah i butchered that wink
we'll move on though also i bet the
story is going to be odsd style with the
taking places
different times with different
characters that would make sense
i i would see something like that
possibly happening
then we got a two dollar trooper set
from dave great work y'all
keep it up and game on and then slow-mo
said literally the only word you have
pronounced correctly is
in years
[Laughter]
shout out to shout out to the slap the
slappiest person on the internet
yeah yeah i appreciate everyone coming
through man